how our electric car subsidized we take
a trip around different countries to see
how they promote the use of electric
cars Norway is thought to have the best
conditions generous subsidies have led
took something of a sales boom the
Norwegian government has made electric
cars virtually tax-free as a result a
cars are sometimes cheaper than
comparable models with conventional
engines drivers of electric cars are
also allowed to use bus lanes they can
park for free and have a good choice of
places to recharge their vehicles
25% of new cars sold in Norway are now
electric models most of them luxury cars
China is the largest market for cars and
hybrid vehicles a hundred eighty eight
thousand of them were sold in 2015 alone
the government offers a six thousand
euro premium to tempt buyers
and in smog plague cities like Shanghai
ich ARS are the only vehicles that are
subject to virtually no restrictions on
purchasing and usage sales have also
been boosted because Beijing made it
mandatory for local authorities to buy
new taxis and delivery vehicles with
alternative drive systems so what about
Germany here buyers get a 4000 euro
reduction on their vehicle fifty percent
of that is financed by the state and the
rest by the car industry 1.2 billion
euros have already been earmarked for
this purpose set to last until 2019 by
2020 the government plans to have 5000
high speed charging points along the
Autobahn and 10,000 standard charging
points in cities but so far demand
remained sluggish since the introduction
of the subsidies few have opted to buy
an electric car